I really want to thank the organizers
for inviting me to share some of my work
under this huge umbrella of decision
medicine 2019 I'm sure we'll be
listening to many experts in the
technology development part so what I'm
gonna do is in my talk is to focus on
the applications of the next generation
generation sequencing technologies in
identifying the drivers of some of the
most aggressive cancers particularly
breast cancer and pancreatic cancer and
prostate cancer so before I begin to go
into the identification of driver driver
genes of aggressive diseases I would
like to mention a little bit about the
precision medicine initiative that was
launched by the National Institute of
Health in 2016 with approximately 130
million dollars that were allocated to
the National Institutes of Health and
about 70 million dollars were allocated
to NCI and the initiative was described
as an emerging approach for disease
treatment and prevention that takes into
account individual variability in genes
environment and lifestyle of each person
and the overall aim of this initiative
was to understand how a person's
genetics environment and lifestyle can
help determine the best approach to
prevent or treat a given disease so with
that we would like to get into what
exactly the the contribution of
next-generation sequencing technology
has been in the precision medicine so
precision medicine actually offers a lot
of advantage over the traditional
cloning based capillary sequencing in
terms of high throughput in terms of
simultaneous monitoring of diverse
components of biology including the gene
expression alternative splicing chimeric
it was
transcripts and many many more and based
on this these advantages there are many
platforms that were developed to
understand home or the transcriptome in
greater detail and some of these
technologies are I have highlighted here
including Illumina sequencing some
official scientific Pacific Biosciences
and nanopore sequencing being the leader
in the market and the although the
platform's of these technologies
sequencing technology sepals are
different but they overall serve as one
single goal and the goal is to obtain
maximum possible information and minimum
possible cost and not surprisingly
next-generation sequencing technology
has emerged and evolved so fast that now
we have been able to bring down the cost
of the genome sequencing or
transcriptome sequencing in a very very
drastic manner so how the question is
how can we use the NGS technologies in
the precision medicine medicine in
diseases so in our lab we study cancers
in particular as I said breast cancer
pancreatic cancer and prostate cancer
and what I'm going to do is to give you
two examples of how the NGS technologies
have enabled us to these diseases and
I'll be talking about two approaches
that our lab has taken in the recent
past one is the sample centric approach
and one is the gene centric approach as
I have highlighted here so a sample
centric approach is where we look at a
particular G then when we look at a
particular sample and we ask what are
the genes or what is a gene that is
deregulated in this particular sample
and can we identify the function of that
particular gene and can be therapy if we
target that
gee so as the name suggests it is a very
simple specific thing a sample specific
approach and one of the one of the
examples of this particulars the success
of this particular approach has been a
report that was published in New York
Times 2012 where a patient with a ll was
treated with sunitinib targeting the
flt3 kinase that was identified to be
deregulated by RNA sequencing while the
whole genome sequencing in the same
patient had failed to identify any
driver mutation or any actionable
mutation in this particular case but as
the name suggests this is N equals one
case so it may not fit all and a ball it
does not take it does not consider the
inter individual heterogeneity of a
patient population the gene centric
approach on the other hand is when we
ask what is a gene or what is a set of
genes that is or are deregulated in
across the population so this kind of
approach is better with long term when
when you have the data clinical data
available for the long term clinical or
the long term follow-up it is also
advantageous in the fact that it also
addresses the inter individual
heterogeneity of a disease and so this
way it can help identify the genes that
may serve as therapeutic targets across
the disease side and in a population at
large but whatever the approach is the
goal is simple the goal is to identify
actionable aberrations and match those
aberrations in patients with available
therapies available targeted therapies
and when we speak about targeted
therapies kindnesses are one of the most
actionable class of therapeutic models
and we have seen many success stories of
different kinase inhibitors in clinics
besides and so in our lab we are focused
on identifying the driver kindnesses
across disease states because they are
easily therapeutically targetable so I
am going to talk about the I am going to
start with the sample centric approaches
in cancer first and then I am going to
talk a little bit on the gene-centric
approaches in identifying the driver
genes so what we did is first of all to
develop a centralized or a generalized
matrix to identify the driver genes in
this particular case the kindnesses
across the disease spectrum we thought
to use the next-generation sequencing
particularly RNA sequencing on about 482
samples from 25 different tissue types
and we look at the entire humankind that
is 468 kindnesses across all these
samples and Here I am highlighting only
the best cancer samples in which we term
which we look in which we look the
kinase for the kindnesses with extreme
expression and we name these kindnesses
as outlier highnesses and as you can see
here that we've used 43 cell lines and
67 tissues for the breast cancer and we
looked for outlier kinases in each of
these samples and you can see that as is
highlighted by these arrows that we have
identified sample specific kindnesses
that have extreme expression in
different tissue types and in the inset
you can also see that there is one
particular sample that is B t47 for cell
line and we have identified a kinase
with extreme expression that's a b2 and
so the question is how did we define our
our outlier
pression of the kindness so we defined
it in terms of the absolute expression
of a particular kindness in that
particular sample versus the
differential expression which is defined
by median level of expression of that
particular kindness across all the
samples so we set up a get cut off in
this particular case that we will look
for the kindnesses that are at least
five fold high or fivefold high
differential expression and at least
twenty rpkm of absolute expression and
we as as is highlighted in the insect
sample specific kindnesses were
identified so the next question is what
is the functional relevance or
therapeutic relevance of these out
lionesses so to have to to assess that
what we did was we used the the cell
lines and we knocked down their
respective outlier kindnesses using
specific s and as you can see here for
example in the top panel the z are 75 30
cell line that expresses high levels of
orbital when we knock down Herbie to
using specific si rnase we get a drastic
reduction in their proliferation while
another gene that is not and how outlier
expression are eks when we knock down
that we don't see any difference in the
proliferation suggesting that this
particular sample is addicted to this
particular kindness and this particular
kinase or b2 in this sample can be used
as a therapeutic target a similar
example is on the bottom panel which is
MD AMD 4 v 3 cell line and here we
identified two outlier cases one is
fgfr4 and one is herbal 2 and on the
right hand side graph you can see when
we knock down the fgfr4 or b2 or both in
combination using either a small
molecule inhibitor or specific as iron a
we can get significant reduction in the
proliferation and this is very important
because in the clinics we have crime and
again seen that the resistance to a
given therapy emerges inevitably so with
that in
find what we thought is which we should
see whether if the resistance to one of
these kinase inhibitors develops can be
used the other kinase as a therapeutic
target and so with that in mind what we
did was we generated a trust assume apps
resistance cell line of MD MBA MB 4 5 3
L in the previous slide we saw that this
particular cell line expresses high
levels of RP 2 so we generated a
transpose of a resistance cell line and
you can see that this particular cell
line is on the bottom left panel you can
see that this is a translucent cell line
that does not respond to trastuzumab
at all but it still responds to fgfr4
inhibition using the PD compound and B
t47 for cells here are used as a
negative control because they do not
express fgfr4 so this data suggests that
if you have more than one outlier
kindnesses in a given sample and if the
therapy if the sample develops are the
resistance to one kind of a kinase
inhibitor you can still use the second
kinase outlier kindness as a therapeutic
target in this particular sample and so
this gives you a lot of room to use
either combination therapy or
intensified therapies so with this
matrix in mind we thought what about
cancers that are highly aggressive such
as pancreatic cancer that is actually
the fourth leading cause of
cancer-related death in the United
States so we use the same matrix to
identify sample specific outlier
kindnesses in about 22 pancreatic cancer
cell lines and 13 issues and again just
like breast cancer we identified sample
specific kindnesses that are that have
very high expression in in respective
samples and as is shown in the insect
the ASP see one cell line expresses
extremely high levels of met kinase and
that's so we can use the met kinase as
therapeutic target in this particular
sample so as a proof of concept what we
did was we again took the outlier kinase
is in a sample specific manner and we
use specific si rnase to down regulate
those minuses here for example on the
upper panel you can see the L 3.3 cell
line which expresses very high level of
EGFR responds very nicely to EGFR
knockdown using specific si rnase in the
middle panel while the axl gene a excel
kinase which is not an outlier kinase in
this particular sample does not provide
any growth advantage or disadvantage
similarly on the bottom panel the BX PC
three cell line which has very high
expression of math and if we knock down
meant using specific si rnase we get a
drastic reduction in the proliferation
rate but any other kind is that is not a
heavily expressed it does not make any
difference to the proliferation now
pancreatic cancer is characterized by or
driven by chaos mutations so we thought
test whether there are cell lines that
are dependent on chaos and whether we
can use and the outlier kindness as a
combination therapy in wit chaos and so
what we did was we took me a Parker to
cells that is a chaos dependent cell
line it has a mutation in chaos and
that's why highly aggressive and in the
background of chaos we the inhibited or
we knockdown plk to using us using a
small molecule inhibitor so in the left
panel of Nia Parker to you can see that
TL k2 is an outlier kinase in here upper
to in the middle panel you see the
shrnas that is red fluorescent stack
that we infected the shrnas for the
Kira's and we have a very almost all the
population expressing the shrna for the
Kira's and so in and in the right panel
you see that combined targeting of chaos
and the PLT to of
a significant disadvantage in growth
rate of Nia occur to cells in the bottom
panel on the other hand we have a Kaos
independent cell line which is bank one
and you can see that neither the Naga
Naga of Kaos nor the inhibition of klk 2
makes any gives it any growth
disadvantage and so this is a
proof-of-concept study that if we
identify an outlier kinase in a given
sample we can use that as a therapeutic
target in that particular sample and
finally we tested the impact of
inhibition of an outlier kindness in a
given sample in the xenograft models so
here we I'm showing you a cell line
called Bank one he drew the xenograft
and treated the xenograft using a kt
inhibitor Excel 184 Bank one expresses
very high levels of a KT and as you can
see that again a KT inhibition in this
particular xenograft resulted in a
drastic reduction in humour row and on
the bottom right you can see a Western
blot showing that the small molecule
inhibitor has very effectively treated
reduce the equity levels in this single
graph so to summarize this part of my
talk we can say that we have
successfully developed a generalizable
matrix to define and prioritize
personalized targets spectra specific to
individual tumors and this is a
proof-of-concept study that outlet/i
nieces can be used as effective
therapeutic targets either alone or in
combination with the known drivers of a
disease for example here asked you can
carry cancer and so this study was a
step forward to the precision medicine
in a truly personalized form so the next
question is what happens when a disease
is not as heterogeneous is much
heterogeneous compared to breast cancer
or pancreatic cancer for example
prostate cancer which is known for its
heterogeneity and is known to be a
multi-step process so typically what
happens is
when a patient is presented in the
clinic with a rise in PSA level he is he
is treated with a localized some form of
a localized treatment for example
radiation therapy followed by which he
experiences a decline in in a biomarker
called prostate specific antigen or PSA
so what happens eventually is that he
experiences the rise in this PSA and at
this point of time he's given the
first-line anti-androgen therapies
because Austrade cancer is driven
primarily by the androgen receptor and
this therapy is called ADP or androgen
deprivation therapy
so after this ADT he acts the usual
procedure PSA level drops down which is
an indication of a responsiveness
eventually and inevitably most of these
cancers develop to disease state called
the castration resistant prostate cancer
and this is characterized by again arise
in the PSA level and at this point of
time patients are offered a second
generation anti-androgen therapies which
is enzalutamide or abiraterone which are
systemic therapies and then what happens
is these therapies definitely over three
to four months advantage survival
advantage but they are not of curative
intent and eventually the patient
progresses to a very advanced and lethal
prostate cancer and so given a
multi-step process of prostate cancer
and given the heterogeneity in prostate
cancer we thought that it would be ideal
to use a gene centric approach to
identify new therapeutic targets apart
from androgen and see whether those
therapeutic targets can be offered but
to do that what we did was we took a
cohort of patients which is Lee which is
characterized by high risk prostate
cancer we collected the radical
prostatectomy samples from these
patience which we obtain from Mayo
Clinic
there are 545 patients in this
particular cohort
and the good thing about this cohort is
that not only we have the expression
data of each of these patients but we
also happen to have a very long term
clinical follow-up data on these
patients which ranges usually between
ten to thirteen years and so with this
kind of data what we can do is we can
establish associations between the gene
expression data and the clinical outcome
data so we looked and we divided this
cohort into two two groups the first
group is patients that experienced
metastasis after radical prostatectomy
and the second group is patients that
did not experience metastasis or
progress to metastases after radical
prostatectomy and we looked at the
kindnesses in each of these two groups
and ranked the kindnesses based on the
fold change in expression as you can see
here in this particular graph so on the
y-axis you have kindnesses that are
ranked by their fold change in
expression and we identified a DNA
dependent protein kinase or a DNA PK as
the top differentially expressed kinase
in patients that subsequently progress
to metastasis
this is highlighted here specifically
with the red bar so the question is what
does the high expression of DNA PK mean
in terms of clinical benefit so we look
for the prognostic impact of DNA PK in
our other cohorts so as you can see here
in the discovery cohort that is the Mayo
Clinic cohort of 545 patients high
expression of DNA PK is associated with
poor metastasis free survive he also
validated our data our observation in a
separate cohort of 355 patients obtained
from John Hopkins and again the same
observation that the high fashion of DNA
PK is associated with poor clinical are
now just like the breast cancer prostate
cancer is also
in the basil and the luminol subtype
with basil is known where the basil is
known for as a less a are driven
prostate cancer luminal is known as the
more a are driven prostate cancer so we
asked what is the prognostic impact of
DNA pk in each of these subtypes of
prostate cancer and as you can see here
in this graph whether the basal or the
luminal DNA PK is prognostic and the
high DNA PK expression is associated
with metastasis free survival in these
subtypes of cancer and finally we also
looked for the publicly he looked at the
expression of DNA PK in Honka mine and
we found that DNA PK is enraged into
metastatic samples head to the primary
in well in 10 out of film cohorts
available and so taken together we this
this data indicates that DNA PK is
highly prognostic in prostate cancer and
is highly associated with metastatic
progression so the next question we
asked is what does the high expression
of DNA PK mean in terms of its
functional significance
so we inhibited DNA PK using a
laboratory grade compound called any 7 4
4 1 or we use specific si RNA is that
targeted be an apk in three different
cell lines c4 to be on the c4 to be is a
castration resistant prostate cancer
cell line so is it in caviar and the PC
3 is an AR independent prostate cancer
cell line and as you can see that the
inhibition of DNA PK resulted in drastic
reduction of the in vitro migration si
in vitro migration of these cell lines
so we wanted to ask what what is it that
DNA PK doing what pathways DNA PK is
regulating so what we did was we we
performed a guilt by association
analysis of DNA PK related pathways
both in the cell line models and in the
clinical samples and we asked what are
the common pathways in the cell line
model and in the clinical samples that
are associated with DNA PK on the in
this graph on the left hand side you can
see on the x-axis we have the clinical
samples and on the y-axis we have cell
lines in which we knock down DNA PK and
we put them together and ask the common
pathways that are regulated by DNA PK
and as you can see the wind signaling
pathway emerged as the top pathway that
is regulated that is associated with DNA
PK in fact when we checked for the wind
pathway members in the in the cell lines
that represent the disease progression
where link cap is a hormone sensitive
cell line and c4 to be and link at a are
are the castration resistant prostate
cancer cell line you see an increasingly
high expression of the width genes in
these cell lines suggesting that the
width pathway is contributing towards
the development of the CRP see the
emergence of wind pathway is has gained
a lot of attraction in very recent past
there are studies that have shown that
as soon as you start treating patients
with localized or localized
ADT or second-generation ADT the wind
pathway emerges there are whole exome
studies and transcriptome sequencing
studies that have shown the deregulation
of wind pathway members in metastatic
prostate cancer samples in fact when we
are treated in capsules which are
hormone naive cells with ADT that is we
grew them in charcoal strip media which
gets rates gets rid of androgen receptor
antigens in the medium the x3 saw that
they start to grow slowly as is seen in
the left hand graph the gray line shows
the cell link capsules that are drawn
hostile Indian they grow slow but
eventually they pick up and just at the
time when they were picking up growth we
looked at the wing vent pathway genes in
this particular at this particular time
and as you can see on the right hand
graph the gray bars denote the elevated
expression of wind genes in these ADT
resistant cells and when we knocked down
DNA PK in these ADT resistant cells you
can see that the expression of all the
wind genes denoted by the red bar come
down to the normal level and in fact
when we when we measure their growth
rates DNA peak a knockdown in these ADP
resistant linked F sells drastically
reduces their proliferation rate
indicating that DNA PK indeed is ready
regulating when signaling so this is
about the link capsule which is a
hormone naive cell what about the
castration resistant cell we looked at
the link at a our cells and also at the
c4 to be cells which are the CRTC cell
lines and we down regulated DNA PK
either using a si RNA or we inhibited
DNA pk using a small molecule inhibitor
no.74 for one and you can see that both
and the mRNA and at the protein level
the will genes go down next question we
asked is whether DNA pk inhibition can
abrogate wind induced cancer phenotype
so as you can see here in these
migration essays on the left hand side
when we induce link AB a are c4 to B
cells with the width 3 a ligand who
induce the wind signaling they get more
aggressive but when we inhibit the DNA
pk in this vent 3 induced state they
stopped migrating indicating that DNA PK
inhibition is impactful in abrogating
the wind induced cancer phenotypes so as
I explained in the prostate cancer
progression earlier that after the
the ADT after the first line EDT
patients are given the second line a DT
which is enzalutamide and heavy retro so
we asked whether DNA pique inhibition is
impactful in enzalutamide treated or
enzalutamide resistance cell lines and
as you can see here that the limb cap a
are cells that were grown to four
enzalutamide resistance they also
respond very nicely to the inhibition of
DNA pk using two different compounds any
seven four four one which is a
laboratory grade compound and CC 1 1 5
which is a clinical grade compound that
is in now in phase one or phase 2
clinical trial so the question is if DNA
PK is regulating when signaling how does
it doing it so mechanistically we we
show that DNA PK actually interacts with
the wind' transcription factor left 1
and as you can see here in these Co IP
grafts when you pull when we pull down
DNA PK we are able to pull down left 1
and vice versa we also show using a
reporter that reads the transcriptional
activity of lef 1 and DNA PK is required
for the transcriptional F so in the
right hand graph if you see when we
induce the cells with wind 3a the
reporter activity goes up but when we
inhibit the DNA PK using any 74-41
the reporter activity drastically goes
down indicating that DNA PK is
transcriptionally required for the left
one function we also perform the
chromatin immunoprecipitation studies
and notice that DNA PK is enriched onto
the regulatory regions of went genes and
that's how it regulates the
transcriptional activity of left 1 when
we inhibit DNA PK using any 74-41
we see a drastic reduction in this
enrichment of DNA PK on the wind genes
we finally tested the impact of DNA pk
inhibition
vivo here we use two different xenograft
models limb cap ear which is a CR PC
xenograft model and PC 3 which is an air
independent xenograft model and we used
DNA peak inhibition using two different
compounds either any 7 4 4 1 or C C 1 1
5 and in the left left most panel you
can see that link a pea xenografts
respond very well to be any PK
inhibition by any 7 4 4 1 in the middle
panel we see that DNA PK inhibitor CC 1
1 5 performs much better than
enzalutamide in reducing the growth of
the xenografts in fact when we gave CC 1
1 5 in combination with enzalutamide we
see a much better reduction in the
xenograft growth in the right hand side
rightmost panel we see a PC 3 xenograft
which is an air independent model of
prostate cancer the that even in this
model DNA PK inhibition is very
impactful introducing the xenograft
growth so to summarize this part we we
can say that the gene centric approach
is using this gene centric approach in
proxy identified DNA PK as the top
expressed it with metastatic progression
of prostate cancer you also show you the
data that inhibition of DNA PK
suppresses the growth of both the ER
dependent and eared independent
phosphate cancer cells and that it does
so by regulating or inhibiting the wind
signaling pathway so with this they're
encouraging data we are testing the DNA
PK inhibition bitter CC 1 1 5 in a phase
one or phase 2 clinical trial in
metastatic CR easy patients in
combination with enzalutamide so what
are we we looking forward to with these
kind of gene-centric core sample centric
approaches that are enabled by a
next-generation sequencing technology
are looking at the the the platforms
like whole genome sequencing
transcriptome sequencing and eventually
that can actually both of these
technical both of these fans both of
these sequencing fans can now identify
different forms of Congo gene activation
different structural variations as we
have finished the whole genome
sequencing of hundred and one metastatic
castrate-resistant prostate cancer
patient but what we are looking forward
to now now is to use integrative
approaches where we can integrate the
whole genome sequencing data with the
transcriptome data and start to see what
are the deregulations in this this kind
of cancers whether and whether these
deregulations can be therapeutically
targetable and so this slide pretty much
summarizes what I just said that
integrative omics approaches can lead us
to achieve maximal clinical benefit so
we can take a patient's tumor and we can
use different approaches that are
enabled by a next-generation sequencing
technology for example genomics or
epigenomics or even immune profiling or
ASCAP tommix and then we can integrate
this data to look for robust biomarkers
we can validate this data to look for
the potential drivers we can do the
network analysis it we can develop the
the matrix or to I to properly stratify
the patients into proper risk groups
that can be benefited by special
therapies or specific therapies we can
look for the small molecule inhibitors
or you know therapies or various kinds
of combination therapies with the goal
of achieving the maximum possible
benefit to the patient good clinical
outcomes and rationally designed
clinical so with that said that
next-generation sequencing technologies
has technologies have enabled us for a
lot but there still remains many
challenges for the precision medicine
initiative and the use of NG
in this particular rare first of all we
need to really standardize the
collection of clinical and Hospital data
and us because this initiative is spread
across the centers in the United States
we need to be able to design databases
to store the large amount of sequencing
data coming from whole genome sequencing
or transcriptome sequencing in in a very
efficient manner we have to also find
ways to protect the participants privacy
and the confidentiality of their health
information we certainly need to develop
a rigorous process of informed consent
and eventually we need to to employ
employee the practices that help us in
loading down the cost so that the
technology is available to a more
population in general and finally in my
own opinion we need a better
understanding of these technologies
through interdisciplinary approaches we
need basic scientists we need band
fusions and we need medical
professionals to come to the other join
hands and brainstorm to identify the
right kind of Trivers for the right kind
of disease for the right kind of
therapies with this I believe that the
future of the next-generation sequencing
technology is in physician medicine look
pride as we say that the picture is
worth a thousand words so we definitely
are unzipping a lot of dark clouds in
this area and we are looking to a bright
future of next-generation sequencing
technology and their application to the
precision precision medicine so with
that I would like to acknowledge a big
team that has helped these kind of
studies and I definitely would like to
acknowledge our funding sources the
Prostate Cancer Foundation and the
Department of Defense or funding our
research and epi take any questions on
this presentation
and I welcome all of you who ask your
questions were emails I'll be I assure
you that I'll be replying the end very
promptly thank you very much